c'est une première pour un ministre en
exercice eric dupond moretti le garde
des sceaux est convoqué devant la cour
de justice de la république ce 16
juillet au matin
il est soupçonné de conflits d'intérêts
à l'origine de la plainte déposée à
l'automne l'union syndicale des
magistrats le syndicat de la
magistrature et l'association anticor
ils contestent le fait qu eric dupond
moretti et ordonné des enquêtes sur des
magistrats dont trois du parquet
financier pnf alors qu'il est leur
ministre des magistrats qui ont géré des
dossiers le concernant selon les
syndicats qui s'étaient mobilisés en
septembre 2020 le garde des sceaux a
voulu régler ses comptes
un ministre de la justice garde des
sceaux ancien avocat qu'il sollicitait
des procédures près disciplinaire à
l'encontre de magistrats ayant eu à
connaître des dossiers le concernant ou
concernant ses anciens clients
nous pensons que nous revenons sur
l'origine du conflit entre les
magistrats et eric dupond-moretti entre
2014 et 2019 le pnf avait pris la
décision d'étudier les relevés
téléphoniques détaillées de dix avocats
pour identifier une taupe chercher à
comprendre qu'ils avaient informé
nicolas sarkozy et son avocat thierry
herzog qu'ils étaient sur écoute dans le
cadre d'une enquête sur une affaire de
corruption
maître dupond moretti avait alors porté
plainte contre x notamment pour atteinte
à la vie privée plainte qu'il avait
retiré dès son entrée en fonction
l'autre affaire implique edouard levraud
ancien juge d'instruction détaché à
monaco eric dupond moretti a assuré la
défense d'un policier mis en examen par
le juge levraud magistrats qu'il a
qualifiés de cow boy pour son action
vigoureuse contre la corruption pour
saisir des documents sur ces affaires
les gendarmes de la section de
recherches de paris ont perquisitionné
les locaux du ministère de la justice le
1er juillet ses avocats ont commenté
garde des sceaux et se rend il a saisi
l'inspection générale de la justice
afin que les magistrats disent si des
manquements déontologiques avait pu être
commis voilà ce qui a donné lieu aux
plaintes déposées par les différents
syndicats de magistrats dont 1
je le rappelle avait qualifié la
nomination d'eric dupond-moretti au
ministère de la justice de déclaration
de guerre
et voilà ce qui explique la perquisition
qui a lieu depuis ce matin
cette mise en cause du ministre ébranle
les institutions juste avant cette
convocation de députés ont présenté leur
démission de la cour de justice de la
république naim amoutchou député la
république en marge du val d'oise a
publié une tribune dans laquelle elle
estime que le désir non dissimulée d'une
poignée de magistrats de réduire à
l'impuissance politique un garde des
sceaux disqualifié dès sa nomination
pose question le député a l'air du val
d'oise antoine savignat a lui aussi jeté
l'épongé à l'issue de la convocation
rick dupond-moretti pour être placé sous
le statut de témoin assisté ou encore
être bien en examen dans ce cas se
poseraient la question de sa démission
pour le moment emmanuel macron a défendu
son garde des sceaux lors du conseil des
ministres assénant qu'il ne laisserait
pas la justice devenir un pouvoir mais
le pouvoir doit aussi rendre des comptes
face à cette même justice